Welcome to the Hugging Face tasks series.
In this video, we will take a look
at the Question Answering task.
Question answering is the task of
extracting an answer in a given document.
Question answering models take a context,
which is the document you want to search in,
and a question and return an answer.
Note that the answer is not generated,
but extracted from the context. This type
of question answering is called extractive.
The task is evaluated on two
metrics, exact match and F1-Score.
As the name implies, exact match looks for an
exact match between the predicted
answer and the correct answer.
A common metric used is the F1-Score, which
is calculated over tokens that are predicted
correctly and incorrectly. It is calculated
over the average of two metrics called
precision and recall which are metrics that
are used widely in classification problems.
An example dataset used for this task is called
SQuAD. This dataset contains contexts, questions
and the answers that are obtained
from English Wikipedia articles.
You can use question answering models to
automatically answer the questions asked
by your customers. You simply need a document
containing information about your business
and query through that document with
the questions asked by your customers.
For more information about the Question Answering
task, check out the Hugging Face course.